SPEAKER 1: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted an almost disturbingly
large number of talks
detailing the future of Cloud.
If you didn't get a chance
to catch the session
called Stackdriver: Monitor,
Debug, Fix, then stay tuned,
because here is the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Stackdriver is a
SAS package for monitoring,
logging, and diagnostics
that help you gain insight
into applications that run
on Google Cloud Platform
and Amazon Web Services.
SPEAKER 2: One big
advantage of Stackdriver
is not having to bounce between
several different web sites
to look at your error
round-up, aggregated logs,
and application
performance monitoring.
SPEAKER 1: To understand
more about how
to use this great tool,
let's take a deeper
look at monitoring.
Every application needs
some sort of monitoring.
And nearly every
application needs
some sort of uptime check.
After that, we want
to monitor things
that are actionable for you.
A good monitor for web app
is the response code ratios.
If I'm getting a certain
number of 400 or 500 responses,
that's a problem I
want to be aware of.
SPEAKER 2: You also want
to monitor your database
to make sure it's keeping up.
One of the cool things
about Stackdriver monitoring
is that it can detect
what you're likely
running on your VM and support
several common third party
tools, including MySQL, Apache,
Cassandra, CouchDB, MongoDB,
Postgres, and many, many more.
For supported services, the
Stackdriver monitoring agent
will discover what
you're running
even if you haven't configured
the server-specific plugin.
It does this by
examining instance names
and looking for specific ports
being opened in firewall roles.
SPEAKER 1: If it finds a
supported third party tool,
it will populate it
in the resources list
to include that service.
There's also metric supported
for many Google services.
For example, you can
monitor the number
of interceptions that
the App Engine does
to prevent DOS attacks, or the
number of operations happening
in a Firebase database,
and the uploaded
bites per minute to BitQuery.
SPEAKER 2: And finally,
most production apps
need some sort of crash or
error reporting and loading.
Stackdriver has an error
reporting tool built in,
so you can subscribe to
alerts and get notified
about new crashes with
automatic throttle back,
so you aren't getting nagged
over and over if everything
is going horribly wrong.
There are several
alerting methods
available, including Slack,
Hipchat, pager, SMS, email,
and the app.
And you can include a custom
message with the alert,
perhaps explaining
what debugging steps
to take if the
alert is triggered.
SPEAKER 1: Once
you get an alert,
you can dig into it using
Stackdriver Error Reporting.
Here is the Error Reporting
dashboard showing some crashes.
You can drill down to see
how many times this error has
happened and, for
App Engine apps,
which version it
first happened in
and which version
it last happened in.
Like monitoring,
an error analysis
works in a hybrid
cloud environment.
There are
language-specific libraries
for the seven main
Google Cloud languages
if you wish to
send your own crash
reports to Error Reporting.
And if you set up
Stackdriver logging,
you get Error Reporting.
SPEAKER 2: Looking a
bit deeper, this error,
you can see the
stack trace, which
offers an idea of where
something may have gone wrong.
The log lets us see more
information about the error,
like the request parameters
and the HTTP response code.
Using the Stackdriver
debugger, you
can figure out what
the application
state is at that point.
The debugger lets you get a
snapshot of the application
state at a given point
during execution.
The runtime debugger currently
supports Java, Python, and Go
applications running on App
Engine or Compute Engine.
SPEAKER 1: Now, if you want
to see Stackdriver in action
with a series of
awesome demos, check out
the full video on YouTube.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget, the
Google Cloud Summit,
coming soon to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]